aoc you're my favorite big booty latina
i love you aoc you're my favorite
this sucks
i love it aoc
hot like a tamale
i mean the last line is kind of funny
the last line is objectively fun yeah
yeah but uh yeah he's a weirdo yeah dude
it's like you're doing something you're
making a girl feel uncomfortable and
you're not doing it because you want to
hit on her it would actually be less
weird if you would go go go yes it would
be less weird if you were doing it
sexually hey i want to be with you
exactly like if your intention was to
get her number yeah if you're like oh my
god you're my favorite big bully latina
god damn you're so beautiful hold on
hold on let me talk can i take you out
for dinner please i love in great point
his intent was to make her feel
uncomfortable that shines through yeah
very obvious yes as an american who
protects women and we treat women the
best at any place in the entire world
that's right dude i have to reject this
because that was un-american